no tienen otra opción en el suroeste de
pakistán cientos de personas abandonan
sus hogares han quedado destruidos en
medio de una temporada de lluvias que
provocó inundaciones que dejan más de
300 fallecidos desde mediados de junio
estuvimos atrapados en el agua de la
inundación durante los últimos tres días
ahora cruzamos el agua a pie hemos
perdido nuestras casas nos queda comida
para nuestros hijos
equipos de rescate junto al ejército
utilizan botes y helicópteros para
ayudar a muchos ciudadanos atrapados la
temporada monzónica ha causado la
destrucción de unas 4000 viviendas y
acabó con otras infraestructuras como
puentes y carreteras
martín nuestro equipo ha llegado a una
de las aldeas que tiene acceso terrestre
y otro equipo está en camino para
recuperar a los aldeanos del área
para los afectados el gobierno está
proporcionando tiendas de campaña
alimentos y otros artículos de
emergencia el ejército también ha
desplegado campamentos médicos la
organización mundial de la salud lanzó
días atrás una campaña para vacunar
contra el cólera la enfermedad que se
transmite por el agua a causa decenas de
muertes y contagiado a miles de personas
en la provincia de baluchistán cada año
se producen brotes de cólera en pakistán
donde muchos ciudadanos no tienen acceso
al agua potable